Tate Goes to Jail gets arrested when
everything is allegedly there's not no
charge or nothing yet right Trump goes
and is being indicted and they 34
different counts and so we have
something bigger but we have something
bigger okay you made this guy fly out
because you wanted that image and you
allowed photographers to get in there
even though they're not it's supposed to
be a drawing that's how typically is
done but you allow photographers to get
in there and then he goes into all these
other people and he says but how many
people got arrested for going to the
Epstein Islands none zero how's that
possible why are we not investigating
that list here who's being protected
who's not that alone
you know what I like about uh Bill Maher
Bill Maher is not a Democrat who defends
Democrats Bill Maher is a liberal who is
now going against the establishment he's
not going against Republicans or Dems he
just can't stand the establishment is
who is pushing back on right well the
establishment is hiding what happened to
Epstein well what happened there you
have access to it you have the
information can we find out can we find
out what happened there or is that uh
crew that is all protecting each other
100 you know protecting each other
that's the part where you start kind of
wondering there has to be something
that's been hidden I don't know who I
asked when I said you think that'll ever
come out he says it'll never come out
who was sitting here that said it'll
never come out oh yeah who was it oh
Charlie Kirk no we did it says that'll
never come out never but but I think in
about 30 years they're gonna do a movie
when you and I are in our 70s we're
gonna go to movies and we're going to
sit and we're gonna say that's crazy we
live through that and nothing happened
it took 30 years for us to see what
happened there's somebody will make the
movie 100 now somebody's got the kahunas
to make that cojones to make that movie
sooner rather than 30 years from now
because a lot of these people that are
part of that are about to die in the
next 10 or 15. yeah but but think about
the secrecy not to cut you off time
think about like the like for the JFK
thing we all we're not stupid we all
know what happened the CIA just recently
said that they all had you know they had
a hand in it that big lie what do you
mean dude that 100 something like that
JFK assassination look how long they've
held the secret like nobody's really
them for him like yeah I know you stay
quiet that Epstein Island bro they are
just they know listen keep your mouth
shut or something's gonna happen to you
that's it they're good and then actually
if you go in Dallas down to this uh to
The Book Depository and you can go up
there to the sixth floor and you can
take a tour and there's this one area
that talks about you know uh
conspiracies and all it says is that
there have been many many conspiracy
theories over the years
and the only thing that they do there is
they let you put on headphones and you
can listen and they tell you would 98
certainty you are going to hear not an
echo but four shots and the thing was
Oswald fired 3 or the book and so after
this many years there's a little glimpse
of Truth they say now we don't know who
did it or where it came from but we can
conclusively say from these Police
radios there were four shots and it's
interesting now
you're right enough years go by and the
truth is going to come out because you
can go down there and there's no longer
that whole exhibit down there is not
Oswald acted alone he shot fired three
times hit Connolly hit Kennedy in the
neck then Kennedy in the head and that's
that magic bullet thank you thank you
very much cue Lyndon Johnson yeah right
no no they you can go down and listen to
it and they'll say there were four shots
fired and they're saying by who well we
don't know and there's a lot of theories
as to who fired up but there were four
shots you know if only four but here we
are 50 years later suddenly that is a
that is that exhibit is operated by the
government as a historical location and
you pay six dollars and go up and take a
tour so long enough that all comes out
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you
foreign